what Troy what did you do to me
hi I'm Julie and I'm Jeff hi I'm
Stephanie hi I'm Troy and today we're
going on a first date trash swap yep I'm
not really too nervous I've checked my
trash I mean it's pretty much mean I got
some things
doodads do they accurately depict me I'm
try not to be too wasteful I might get
judged a little bit oh yeah I am nervous
hopefully we'll have some fun checking
it out let's do it all right got this
ready whoo bring on the trash don't
judge me too hard dominoes listen I get
home late some nights from work and I
just like to order pizza
this is delicious I am really impressed
by this thank you people people don't
even like the gist the berries like
that's all I need I don't need to other
stuff you're a snacking guy huh big time
let's see Louie what is Lily
restaurant gourmet market your almond
fan are you like I have to kind of eat
healthy a lot of the time oh she is
fancy I heard her dose oat milk that's
like all the kids are talking about huh
there are more awesome snacks in here
this looks delicious I like really like
your eating choices I knew we were gonna
be best friends when we walked in yes
this tells me that Troy has a drinking
problem I mean I dabble in the white
cloth there's no laws out here I love I
always get these earrings oh yeah salad
in avocado you want to know how many
times I've eaten sattell in my life 14
what that can't be true fax me mark hey
we need to we need to discuss your
nutrition so we got a script here or
some some side says tells me you're
obviously an actor seen that before he's
gonna do a dramatic role yes
one piece of paper for you is so much
more involved in herself really commit
you know what your suffering is not the
most important thing in the world to
everyone there are billions of billions
of billions of people and nations all
over the world could never invent think
of it and this tells me that Troy here
is not not you a newspaper reader
I mean print media is going out of style
man it's not like we work in media or
anything I think it like came as like
packing material I wish that I could
just like that's like I don't sit coffee
I don't read newspapers you don't drink
coffee person are you a great person
[Music]
so Stephanie yep
likes the club I'm assuming this is like
a club bracelet right this is uh no what
is it like a festival yeah I was gonna
say yes it is this is a DC how did you
know that I went to back in 2010 when it
used to be well I'm also into
electronics oh there we go
so you know what it's like a birthday
card I did keep the card I just throw
away the envelope so this isn't his car
right here hey get me in trouble
what is this UCB yeah yeah I took improv
classes and then that expired so I throw
it away
Oh Stephanie is well-traveled yeah she's
well just went to Mexico City recently
it's accurate I say that you like to
travel and explore new cities so that's
good so that's a that's a sports
clothing laughs but I got a what I can't
think I got a USA basketball shirt for
that one
you are so your sports fan mm-hmm
basketball basketball football
volleyball in different sports they're
fun
like if you I like the snacks watching
well the Dodgers have great snacks I'm
guessing I'm guessing I'm not alone on
the person that buys a lot of supplies I
don't have enough money to do it but I
do it anyway
ain't that all of us yeah you don't even
pop any of them he's not as loud but
yeah so this tells me that Troy here
receives coupons and chooses not to use
them which is not a very Jewish
[Laughter]
okay I had to change my windshield
wipers I did myself I know it's really
easy but it took me like four days to
figure it out
you said it was really easy I've never
done that by myself so that's awkward
I got right here there's not a fan of a
bargain earlier I said I don't know what
to believe it all piles up well she
likes to do things herself I think I
think that because a lot of people
wouldn't want to deal with anything cars
by themselves and she's healthy well
just from this that seems like he's a
little unhealthy really like the coupons
he's not he's not saving I'll tell you
that no a box of macaroni a day keeps
the doctor away that's what that's the
phrase mm-hmm I was thought it was an
apple but you know what Troy oh wait I
thought this was a soft you got the same
all right you want to know what I assume
about Troy I assume that he thinks every
date is gonna pick up his [ __ ] and he's
gonna be down to deal with his dirty you
saw thank you it's like did you make a
crop top yes got it
[Laughter]
hey you know we just out here trying to
have a good time go be safe okay today's
what brain disease sat in my car for
like a year and now it's bad and okay
threw it out
how's it say you gotta be saved why you
throw it away because I'm trying to be
safe true true this is something I like
that song talk about see I mean you can
hang up I already know you crushed us
all on your own there I mean I wouldn't
say hopefully my mom's I watch bikes
have fun and gets you you know maybe you
just like took took it out these are all
this is a facial roller a facial I don't
what do you do with this what do you
think you do with it rolling on it what
does it do is it it's fully I don't know
it's like a self-care I you roll your
skin as suppose they're just like
increased blood circulation one of my
best friend gave it to it so you get so
you got ultra beauty so will we you got
a bunch of makeup yeah I'm obsessed with
skincare I can't tell you I've been I
don't want to lie to you on TV but I'm
happy for you
skin care should be for men and women
just saying I would assume he's a
typical guy I feel like he knows that I
have a good time but he also is very
conscious about like being put together
and you know you're not like totally
just like off the deep end which is good
to know what i can assume about stuff
that she obviously travels she's an
actor she eats healthy and she's funny
so I appreciate good first-date for me
yeah so out of this um I think she's a
she's a shopper she definitely knows
what she's doing around the car which is
always good she's healthy she take care
of her stuff also stuff she likes snakes
she appreciates snack so you're a guy
that knows how to have fun I I can see
that and you're not a coffee addict
which I guess is healthy but the rest of
it I don't know man uh I respect all of
your snack choices I think that it just
points to how cool and fun you are I
think we could totally have a she was
funny I feel like we could have we'd
have a good conversation and stuff we
hung out so yeah I think trash mops are
definitely good for throat for first
dates because we learned so much about
each other next time we should like
bringing Bowl
[Music]